We should it be given to this next logical reason many
people misconception that zakat can be given
to same people and zakat can be
given as for the category of two
people and there is no other
category mentioned as zakat in it but it can only be given
to person who is very poor and needy and
dozens have the provision who dozens have food assets
so it is not the same category in fact it is much more
limited as added to the category of zakat
as it is clearly mentioned in the hadi of Sunan Abu
Dawood number two in the book of Zakat hadi number
1605 the blessed prophet sallam said that give
zakat al fitr for the
fast from most talks and obscene
talks to feed the poor
people and it should be given before the salah if it is before the salah  It is
called Zakat. If it is given
after the Eid al-Fitr Salah, it is called Sadaqah. So,
based on this hadith, we have come to note that it should be given only
to the very poor people, miskin
people, who do not have enough food to eat. So, at least
the day of Eid will be restless
and I will go happy. That is why it should be given before the Eid al-
Fitr Salah. It is for the normal Zakat at any time
of year. But there are some reasons why you can give it
to a trustworthy person who can give
the food on time to some big person. It is difficult
for you to find a true person who is very poor and
very needy. You do have food. So, you can give it to the trustworthy
person and you can give it to another
organization and collect it. In this case, it can be given either, but it should be given only to
the person who gets this food.
Given to the poor people and get the money from which
food is purchased and given to people the
recipient should receive it only in the kind
of food and should receive it before the Salah
prefer in the morning before they go for the Salah
of Eid and couple of days before it the Hadaqaam is it in
Bukhari number
in the Book of Representation Hadaqa number 211 Now
it is mentioned that the Messenger of Allah (peace be upon him) had
appointed me to collect the Zakat Fitr Sadaqa of
Ramadan so he was appointed for that so it means you can give it to someone on before so he can give
to the people and it is also mentioned as
Hadaqa or
Ima person who does not do Umar when he used to give
the Zakat Fitr Sadaqa of Ramadan so the reply was
after the collector finish collecting the
amount when did the collector finish the
reply was one and two days  Before Eid it means it can be given
to collector or someone who has been
deputed to collect and then that person
should see the recipient at the right time
before the Fitr Salah and should receive it in the form
of food and nothing else.